This is why for
most classification tasks
people tend to hold back more than
30,000 examples for validation.
This makes accuracy figures significant
to the first decimal place and
gives you enough resolution
to see small improvements.
If your classes are not well balanced,
for example,
if some important classes are very rare,
this heuristic is no longer good.
Bad news, you're only going
to need much more data.
Now, holding back even 30,000 examples
can be a lot of data if you have
a small training set.
Cross-validation, which
I've mentioned before,
is one possible way to
mitigate the issue.
But cross-validation
can be a slow process,
so getting more data is
often the right solution.